[Music]
on this sunday night
thankful to finally be together a
canadian cancer patient
and her british partner are reunited
thanks to cross-border travel changes
recovery has been a lot more difficult
physically with
this this other fight but it's still not
the case for so many others this holiday
weekend
the rcmp bans mounties from wearing a
long-held symbol of police solidarity
but has the thin blue line become a
symbol of division
left without a child or answers where's
my twelve thousand dollars what do i
what do i get for them after a
financially struggling adoption agency
shuts down and the young canadians
carrying the torch of change on this
international day of the girl
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
colleen christie good evening thanks for
joining us an ontario woman has a lot to
be thankful for this long weekend
the pandemic forced sarah campbell to
spend months
separated from her fiance because he
lives overseas
during that time she had to endure
cancer surgery without him by her side
after months of begging ottawa for help
the federal government
finally lifted travel restrictions this
month allowing more types of family
members to come to canada including
sarah's fiance as jeff semple explains
hundreds of other canadians are still
waiting to find out when they can see
their loved ones again
sarah campbell has waited eight months
for this moment
as soon as i saw the car turned down the
street i started crying and
kind of hyperventilating she and her
british fiance jacob were supposed to
get married in june
and begin their life together in canada
but the pandemic border closure meant he
wasn't allowed to enter the country
we realized number one that we would
have to postpone our wedding and
number two i i found a lump on the side
of my neck
in july she was diagnosed with stage two
thyroid cancer forced to endure surgery
with jacob stuck
in the uk fighting cancer but also
fighting just to have my fiance by my
side as i
as i go through this it's a twofold
fight that no one should ever
ever have to go through but many others
did
campbell joined an online campaign of
thousands calling on the canadian
government to open the border to
unmarried couples and those with a dying
relative
like arthur santiago charlie i can see
it in her eyes she's just holding on
to see her family his wife has stage
four
cancer doctors say she may only have
weeks left to live
and she wants to see her sister who
lives in the philippines
but their request for a visit was denied
but what we do not understand
is how compassionate exemptions were not
here from day one
long-term relationship last week the
government finally changed the rules
now accepting applications from
committed couples extended family
members
and others on compassionate grounds the
government has already received
hundreds of applications it was it's
amazing because
this weekend santiago received good news
my wife and her sister will be able to
see each other our flight is booked
she's flying in on thursday and they'll
be able to be with each other before
it's too late
and among the first to be approved to
enter canada under the new rules
campbell's fiance jacob honestly it felt
like a dream
her weak immune system meant she
couldn't meet him at the airport so she
waited outside of her parents
house
i basically just launched myself at him
yeah i was sort of worried i was going
to hit the tarmac
i was i mean jacob is now isolating in
the basement for two weeks
though they are allowed distanced visits
in the yard just in time for
thanksgiving
but i'm just thankful that he's in the
same house in the same country
that the day after his quarantine is
done the couple plans to get married
before sarah begins radiation treatment
in november
this time with her fiance by her side
jeff semple global news toronto turning
now to the covet 19 situation across the
country for the first time since
wednesday quebec recorded fewer than 1
000 daily cases it added 942
new infections today ontario is also
seeing a slight drop in cases
649 people tested positive for the virus
in the last 24 hours
in the u.s covet 19 isn't stopping the
republicans on two fronts tonight u.s
president donald trump is preparing for
several campaign rallies this week
after his doctors declared him no longer
a transmission risk
and battle lines are being drawn as the
senate judiciary committee prepares for
hearings to confirm judge amy coney
barrett to the supreme court jennifer
johnson has more
the stage is set for a showdown between
senate republicans and democrats
over confirming judge amy coney barrett
to the u.s supreme court
democrats argue the next high court
justice a lifetime appointment
should be picked by the president
elected november 3rd early voting has
already begun in several states
she is being sent on assignment to the
supreme court
by president trump and we know what that
assignment is
eliminate the affordable care act
democrats fear the capitol hill hearing
could become another super spreader
two of the judiciary committee members
senators mike lee and tom tillis
tested positive for the virus after
attending coney barrett's nomination
ceremony at the white house
two weeks ago senate republicans will
follow the guidance the medical guidance
of the capital physician
barrett is expected to be grilled on her
conservative stances on abortion and
same-sex marriage
i'm feeling great i don't know about you
how is everyone feeling barrett will be
in the hot seat
as the white house releases a letter
from the president's physician
saying he's no longer a transmission
risk for covid19
but not saying if he's tested negative
for the virus i'm immune so
so the president is in very good shape
to fight the battle on saturday new
coven 19 cases
hit their highest mark since august
record numbers reported in six states
what we thought might be just a bump
after labor day clearly is a resurgence
in the virus heading into the fall in
the winter you've seen cases built
across the entire country
there's now about 15 states with a
positivity rate above 10 percent
while on the campaign trail democratic
candidate joe biden has blasted
president trump for downplaying the
pandemic
we lose anywhere from 700 to a thousand
people a day
dead but the newly invigorated president
will take his message
not to fear the virus to his base at
rallies planned this week in key swing
states
jennifer johnson global news washington
the u.s is now no longer the only
country in the world to have more than
7 million confirmed cases of covet 19.
india reached the grim milestone today
adding another 74 000 cases in the last
24 hours
india is on track to surpass the u.s to
become the pandemic's worst hit country
in the coming weeks
experts say the true number of
infections may be much higher because
testing rates are lower in india than in
many other countries
people living in england are bracing for
tighter covet 19 restrictions the
country's prime minister is expected to
back a new three-tier
local lockdown system tomorrow it can
force pubs and restaurants in pandemic
hot spots to temporarily close
england's deputy chief medical health
officer says the uk is now
at a tipping point without action
there's fear uk hospitals will be
overwhelmed in the coming weeks
the rcmp has told mounties they are no
longer to wear an
image that's used to show solidarity
with police and their families
it's a black and white canadian flag
with a thin blue line
but it's not an official symbol of the
rcmp
as catherine urquhart explains it comes
as police organizations are examining
their relationships with minority
communities
they're known around the world for their
red surge dress uniform
members of the rcmp are strictly guided
by a uniform and dress manual their
appearances are now the focus
of a controversial internal memo about
members wearing
a thin blue line my reaction was one of
surprise
and concern on friday mounties across
the country
received a directive saying in part
the subdued flag with a blue bar has
become widespread in north america
as a sign of solidarity and support for
police
while this may be common it is not an
approved symbol
and is not to be worn on our uniform
growing scrutiny of the police and calls
for reforms are also referenced in the
edict
which states we have been a focal point
in difficult
public conversations about the role of
police in our society
within policing communities across north
america the thin blue line has long been
a symbol of support for one another
it really depicts the line the police
officers walk
every day keeping society free
from chaos but critics say the symbol
ignores the larger issue of police
violence against
racialized communities and promotes an
us versus them mentality it has a much
and i'm going to use this word
deliberately much darker side
that is very much associated with being
anti-black lives matter
being you know pro-racial profiling
regardless of criticism and the rcmp
directive
many officers are vowing to continue
wearing the thin blue line
we've also commissioned some custom blue
line patches
and we'll be sending them out to all of
our members across canada
members who don't adhere could face code
of conduct reprimands
rcmp management perhaps forced to choose
between supporting the rank and file and
pressure to make
changes to the face of policing in
canada
katherine cart global news vancouver for
the first time since january
china has granted consular access to two
detained canadians
in a statement global affairs says
canada's ambassador to china
was granted virtual access to michael
spavor on friday and
michael coverig on saturday the two men
have been detained in china for nearly
two years
they were taken into custody in 2018
shortly after the arrest of huawei
executive mangwon zhou
in vancouver residents in parts of
louisiana are dealing with flooded
streets
and downed trees after the second
hurricane in six weeks
more than 400 thousand homes and
businesses were in the dark this morning
after hurricane delta
hammered the state the storm hit just
weeks after hurricane laura a category 4
storm devastated the region this
atlantic hurricane season has broken
several records including the first time
there have been
10 named storms to make landfall in the
u.s
a temporary cease-fire between armenia
and azerbaijan looks
anything but peaceful at least five
people died overnight after a rocket hit
the azerbaijani city of ganja overnight
both countries agreed to a russia-backed
truce that went into effect yesterday
but two weeks of fighting in the
disputed region of nagorno-karabakh
continues
azerbaijan is accusing armenia of
targeting civilians in this latest
attack
ganja city is more than 100 kilometers
away
from the theater of military operations
what was the reason to attack with
sweetie what was the reason to attack
minga chevy city of azerbaijan
there is no military targets it doesn't
have any necessity
no way it can be just justified from the
military necessity
and the armenian government denies the
claim calling it an absolute lie
and blaming azerbaijan of shelling
armenian populated areas of
nagorno-karabakh
the enclave is legally part of
azerbaijan but largely inhabited and
controlled by ethnic armenians
the two weeks of fierce fighting has
left more than 300
dead coming up saskatchewan's first
safe drug consumption site opens but is
it too little
too late and megan the duchess of sussex
opens up about online abuse
it has been one of the deadliest years
on record for overdoses in saskatchewan
this month the province opened its first
supervised drug consumption site
but as kyle benning reports advocates
say more needs to be done to save lives
for dawn wilson a supervised consumption
site could have been a lifeline for her
son
he overdosed five times in four years
knowing that there are people there who
could talk to him who would help him
um who would make referrals for him yeah
otherwise you know he's just wandering
the streets sleeping in
back alleys using used needles like it
was
at the end it was horrible from january
to august this year
the saskatchewan coroner's service says
there have been 40 confirmed
and 190 suspected overdose deaths for a
total of 230.
that's nearly three times as many that
took place in 2010
and nearly a 70 increase from 2019's
figures
the executive director of prairie home
reduction is not mincing words over the
province's response
to saskatchewan's drug crisis a joke
jason merkerty says he hasn't seen any
urgency addressing overdose deaths
so they can talk all they want about
around around the issue
the result is we have people dying so we
need to deal with this immediate issue
when the province declined to give phr
any of the 1.3 million dollars it
requested to run the site this year
it raised enough money on its own to
hire a paramedic to open
it's the only health canada approved
drug consumption site between calgary
and thunder bay dawn wilson was able to
find private treatment services for her
son
but she believes the public doesn't see
everything a safe consumption site can
provide
because they don't realize they're
talking about people's children spouses
like no one's immune to this right
and yeah it's much needed and i think
people just don't understand what harm
reduction means
saskatchewan is midway through an
election campaign the ndp says it would
fund the site if elected
and the saskatchewan party says it won't
rule that out either
kyle benning global news saskatoon
still ahead left in limbo what happens
when a couple pays for an adoption
but the agency goes under
watching global national
[Music]
when a british columbia adoption agency
suddenly closed last year potential
parents who'd spent
thousands of dollars in hopes of
building their families were left in
limbo
at the time choice's adoption said it
was because of a drop in
international adoptions the main source
of its funding
but global news has uncovered documents
that show the agency had been in trouble
for years
robin gill reports
patricia and erin pearson know how lucky
they are to have a daughter
her art is everywhere in the house but
it wasn't easy to conceive
so when they decided to grow their
family they turned to adoption
you go into adoption knowing there are
no guarantees
and knowing that it's going to be a
roller coaster
but i think our journey has had more
ups and downs and and the journey of
other people in our situation
than would normally be expected they had
no qualms paying 12
thousand dollars to an agency called
choices but the adoption they so
desperately wanted
never happened if we paid for a couch
and we didn't get a
couch there would be a recourse we would
be able to sue someone or do something
we've now paid essentially to bring a
child into our family and there's
there's no recourse i can't go to anyone
and say
where's my twelve thousand dollars what
do i what do i get for that what are you
going to do for me
for 30 years choices was a reputable
not-for-profit organization
there was never an audit but global news
has obtained one accounting firm's
review which found choices was running a
107
thousand dollar deficit in 2018. because
of those financial problems the board
decided to close the agency in april
2019. then a new board came in
to try to save it but they soon realized
the money problems were far worse than
they were led to believe
choices closed for good in october of
that same year
up to 90 families were left in the lurch
and the agency was still
taking money even though a document
showed the board was
adamant choices not take on any new
clients
months before they closed we knew that
there was people that were registering
with choices
within the two weeks prior to them
closing the minutes from board meetings
show robin pike who ran the agency for
seven years
insisted all along the agency was viable
we tried three times to contact robin
pike who ran the agency for seven years
hi this is robin pike please leave me a
message
she never returned our calls
now the pearsons have to start the
difficult process all over again
what do you think was worse the
emotional investment or the financial
investment
emotional 100 yeah despite the emotional
toll they're not ruling out adoption and
still want to welcome another child
into their family robin gill global news
victoria
in part two of our story we'll take a
look at the steps some families are
taking to get answers about how the
money they paid the agency was spent
that's tomorrow on global national up
next the canadian girls trying to change
the world and how one woman
is honoring them
megan the duchess of sussex says opened
up about the online abuse she received
since joining the royal family this
weekend she and her husband prince harry
joined a podcast called
teenager therapy as part of world mental
health day
megan spoke about online trolling during
her conversation with students from a
california high school
i'm told that in 2019 i was the most
trolled person in the entire world
male or female but what was able to just
be manufactured and churned out
it's almost unsurvivable five teenagers
created the groundbreaking podcast to
explore mental health issues
today is international day of the girl a
day that began
nine years ago to amplify the voices of
young women and advocate for equal
rights
this pandemic has been particularly hard
on women impacting everything from
child care to increased domestic
violence but as heather urex west
explains young canadian voices are
providing hope
that change is possible hi
charlene rocha is a 16 year old activist
determined to change
the world i'm really involved with the
climate movement that's one thing i'm
really passionate about
but i'm also really involved with gender
equality my name is charlene rocha and
i'm a youth activist and striker rocha
who was recently featured in a
documentary about young activists
says she's been inspired by the young
women who've come before her
people like greta toonberg this is just
the beginning
we will continue and canadian activist
autumn peltier i'm lending my voice to
speak up for water
and mother earth it's that kind of
inspiration that former conservative mp
rona ambrose is hoping to provide in a
new book
that celebrates girls around the world
there's nine girls from nine different
parts of the world and of course we have
a canadian girl her name is sokonen
but she's actually based on the true
life story of shannon
it's hard to feel pride when your
classrooms are cold
and mice run over our lunches in 2008
13 year old kostashian began advocating
for a new school to be built in her
community
on the atawapascat first nation her
campaign became a rallying cry for
educational rights for indigenous
children across the country
sadly kastashian died in a car accident
at the age of 15
but on these pages her story lives on
inspiring a new generation of young
women like charlene rocha
to pick up the torch and keep working
towards change
my hope for the future is that girls all
across the world
are able to really embrace themselves
and stand up for causes that they
believe in
heather urex west global news calgary
that is global national for this sunday
i'm colleen christie tonight's your
canada is
all the beautiful fall colors near birds
creek in ontario
we love showcasing your part of canada
email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching and happy
thanksgiving